THOMAS PATTERSON: Etched in stone in the rotunda
of the Capitol are the words "Here, sir, the
people govern."
Those words were spoken by Alexander Hamilton
when he asked what Congress represented.
To the framers of the Constitution, the Congress
was the first branch of government, the place
where the people's representatives met to
decide the people's business.
Yet when the Constitution was unveiled, many
leading Americans were outraged.
One of them was Richard Henry Lee of Virginia,
who had been president of the Continental
Congress during the Revolutionary War.
Richard Henry Lee said, "This Constitution
has very little democracy in it."
What he was objecting to was the fact that
the people were not allowed to vote for the
president or for members of the Senate.
Only the House of Representatives would be
chosen by a vote of the people.
When Henry Clay of Kentucky, one of the great
legislators of the 19th century, left the
Senate to run for the House, he said, "I prefer
to serve in the people's chamber."
Some critics today wonder whether that label
still applies to the House.
They point to House elections, which have
become increasingly expensive.
It was not that long ago that these were relatively
modest affairs, funded largely by donations
from people living in the district.
Today, it's easily the case that a House election
can cost $1 million or more, with much of
that money coming from wealthy individuals
and groups from outside the district.
Critics also point to redistricting, the tendency
of state legislatures to pack House districts
with voters from a particular party, thereby
guaranteeing the election of that party's
candidate in the fall.
So who's doing the electing?
Is it the voters?
Or is it the state legislatures and the wealthy
donors?
Those kinds of issues about self-government
have been part of the American debate since
the writing of the Constitution.
[MUSIC PLAYING] Over the course of American
history, few features of the Constitution
have been subject to more debate or more manipulation
than its provisions for representative government.
In this session, we'll look at the Constitution's
provisions for representative government,
a government in which the people rule through
their representatives.
We'll start by examining the Constitution's
initial provisions for representation and
then explain how and why they were changed.
We'll then turn to voting laws and how they
have affected the public's role.
Finally, we'll look at a couple of current
issues, voter ID laws and congressional redistricting.
Before I start, I have a question for you
to think about.
In your view, what's the bigger threat to
how democracy in America is practiced?
Is it public officials, those who set the
rules for elections, or is it the people themselves,
who can weaken democracy by not bothering
to vote or voting even when they're not eligible
to vote?
I'm not going to answer the question for you.
I want you to think about it.
When the delegates gathered in Philadelphia
in 1787 to write the Constitution, they had
a number of factors that had to be taken into
account.
Their first was that the states had their
own governments and intended to keep them.
In addition, the states differed greatly in
size and wealth.
Powerful states like Virginia and New York
were not interested in a union that failed
to recognize their prominent role.
At the same time, small states like Rhode
Island and Delaware were not interested in
a union where their interests would be pushed
aside.
There was also the question of the role the
people would play.
Under the nation's first constitution, the
Articles of Confederation, members of Congress
were chosen by the states.
Voters had no say whatsoever in the selection
of their representatives.
That would not work under the new constitution.
The national government would have the power
to tax the people.
They would likely rebel if denied all say
in the election of federal representatives.
These considerations were resolved by what
has come to be called the Great Compromise,
the decision to create a two-chambered Congress,
the House and the Senate.
The House would have members in proportion
to each state's population, elected by the
voters to two-year terms.
This arrangement satisfied the larger states--
they would have a bigger share of House seats--
and also served to satisfy those who believed
the people should have a direct vote.
In contrast, the Senate would have two members
per state, chosen by the state legislatures
for six-year terms.
This arrangement satisfied the concerns of
small states.
They would have equal representation in the
Senate.
It also mollified those who wanted the states
to have a say in the selection of federal
officials.
State interests also figured into the method
of choosing the president.
Pennsylvania's James Wilson twice proposed
that the president be popularly elected.
Twice the delegates voted him down.
A proposal to have Congress choose the president
was also rejected.
That method would have weakened the president's
ability to act as a check on the Congress.
Congress would pick presidents who promised
to do its bidding.
Having pretty much run out of ideas, the framers
invented what has come to be called the Electoral
College.
Each state would have as many electors as
it had members of Congress, House and Senate
combined.
The state legislatures would choose the electors,
and the candidate with the majority of the
electoral votes would become president.
Thomas Jefferson was 3,000 miles away when
the Constitution was written, serving as US
Ambassador to France.
He admired many of the Constitution's features,
particularly its separation of powers.
But Jefferson worried that the people had
been given too little power.
Jefferson also thought officials should be
term limited.
If not, they might come to believe that public
office was theirs by right.
Other critics noted the contrast between the
Constitution's provisions and what the states
were doing.
In nearly all states, governors and legislators
were chosen by direct popular vote.
Why should the national government be any
different?
In defending the Constitution's provisions,
the framers argued that the history of unrestrained
democracies was the history of tyranny, where
the many trampled on the rights of the few.
Said James Madison, "Pure democracies have
ever been spectacles of turbulence and contention
and have in general been as short in their
lives as they have been violent in their deaths."
The framers even had a homegrown example,
Rhode Island, to prove their point.
In that state, debtors had gained control
of the legislature and concocted a scheme
for getting rid of their debt.
They passed a law authorizing the use of paper
money, which was largely worthless, to pay
debts incurred by borrowing gold.
Creditors were hunted down, tied up in public
places, and people lined up to pay off their
debts with the worthless paper money.
Soon the Rhode Island economy was a wreck,
with inflation running at 800%.
Most of its shops had shut down, and creditors
had fled the state.
A Boston newspaper labeled the state Rogue
Island.
The framers were so convinced of the dangers
of democracy that they refused even to call
the new government a democracy.
They called it instead a republic.
The people would have a voice in the government,
but it would be filtered through representative
institutions, only one of which, the House,
would be subject to direct election.
The Constitution, said Madison, was "a republican
remedy for the ills of uncontrolled democracy."
Now whether intended or not, the Constitution's
provisions for representative government virtually
guaranteed that the federal government would
initially be controlled by wealthy or otherwise
prominent Americans.
Through the first six presidents, very few
small farmers, craftsmen, or merchants were
elected to Congress or held high-ranking executive
positions, even though they made up the vast
majority of the population.
That situation changed with the election of
the seventh president, Andrew Jackson.
Raised in poverty by a widowed mother in the
backwoods of Carolina, Jackson won national
fame as commanding general at the Battle of
New Orleans, where US forces defeated the
British in the War of 1812.
Upon assuming the presidency, Jackson appointed
ordinary citizens to executive office and
pressured states to eliminate property ownership
as a requirement for voting.
He tried but failed to get rid of the Electoral
College but then persuaded the states to tie
their electoral votes to the popular vote.
Jackson's system is the one we have today.
The winner of a state's popular vote receives
its electoral votes, giving the voters a decisive
say in the choice of the president.
Seven decades later, the Constitution was
amended to provide for the popular election
of senators.
The Senate had become a corrupt institution.
Powerful corporations had bribed and bullied
state legislatures to choose senators who
would protect their interests.
The ensuing scandals helped fuel the Progressive
movement, which was the leading force behind
the amendment.
The Progressives also challenged the party
machines that had taken over control of candidate
nominations.
They succeeded in getting states to adopt
primary elections, where the voters rather
than the party organizations chose the nominees.
As you might have noted, these changes basically
undid the work of the framers.
The presidency, House, and Senate were now
all subject to vote of the people, who had
two chances to be heard, once in the primary
and once in the general election.
This was a remarkable change.
At the beginning of the republic, the people
had a relatively small voice in their governing.
Today, as has been true ever since the Progressive
Era, the United States has more elections
for national office than any other democracy.
Lots of elections doesn't mean that Americans
vote regularly.
In fact, the United States has nearly the
lowest voting rate among Western democracies.
As this chart indicates, the voting rate in
US presidential elections is roughly 60%,
below that of other leading democracies.
In some countries, Italy being an example,
the rate exceeds 80%.
To understand why the United States lags behind,
we need to go back to the writing of the Constitution.
As originally written, the Constitution did
not provide for the right to vote.
Some Americans were held in slavery and were
denied even citizenship.
For their part, women were thought not to
have a rightful place in public affairs.
Not until ratification of the 19th Amendment
in 1920 did women get the right to vote.
The original Constitution had a single clause
on voting.
It gave the states authority to determine
voting eligibility in federal elections, saying
only that a state's restrictions on voting
could not be greater than those placed on
voting for members of the largest chamber
of the state's legislature.
That clause seemed harmless at the time.
But it has turned out to be a source of mischief.
It has been used at times to deny some people
the right to vote.
In the early history of the United States,
most states denied the vote to males without
property, a policy that Ben Franklin thought
worthy of ridicule.
"Today," wrote Franklin, "a man owns a jackass
worth $50 and he is entitled to vote.
But before the next election, the jackass
dies and the man cannot vote.
Who's the voter, the man or the jackass?"
By the 1830s, urged on by Andrew Jackson,
nearly all states had dropped the property
requirement.
The ugliest chapter in America's voting history
began in the South after the Civil War and
lasted nearly a century.
The 15th Amendment, which was ratified soon
after the war, prohibits states from denying
the vote on the basis of race or color.
When Northern troops left the South a decade
after the Civil War ended, the South's white-majority
governments concocted every trick imaginable
to keep blacks from voting.
Louisiana wiped clean its registration rolls
and required its residents to re-register.
The state made it so hard for blacks to re-register
that less than one in 10 were able to do so.
Throughout the South, literacy tests and poll
taxes were adopted.
In order to register to vote, citizens had
to pass a literacy test and pay a tax.
To ensure that white voters were not disenfranchised
by these requirements, a grandfather clause
was placed in the law.
Anyone whose father or grandfather had been
eligible to vote was exempt from the requirements.
Obviously, no former slave or child of a slave
qualified for that exemption.
The Supreme Court waited until 1915 before
declaring the scheme unconstitutional.
Whites-only primaries were also devised.
The Democratic Party was in control throughout
the South.
Every governor, every state legislature, and
nearly every member of Congress was a Democrat.
As a result, the key election throughout the
South was the Democratic primary.
Whoever won that primary was virtually assured
of winning the general election.
Blacks were prohibited from voting in primaries.
The Supreme Court waited until 1944 to strike
down that practice.
The Court refused, however, to strike down
literacy tests and poll taxes, and they effectively
kept blacks away from the polls.
The literacy tests were so difficult that
those administering them had to look up the
answers and were given discretion in determining
whether an applicant had passed.
Whites routinely did.
Blacks who scored as high or higher were frequently
told they had failed.
In some places, it took courage even to apply
for the vote.
The local newspaper would publish the names
of those who had applied so that white employers
would know which blacks not to hire.
In the entire state of Mississippi, fewer
than 5% of eligible blacks were registered
to vote even as late as the 1950s.
The Voting Rights Act of 1965 brought an end
to these tricks.
The legislation empowered federal officials
to register voters in states and counties
with histories of racial discrimination.
In less than two years, black registration
in Mississippi had jumped tenfold.
In Alabama, it climbed from less than 20%
to over 50%.
The Voting Rights Act produced a regional
split in Congress not seen since.
The Senate vote was 77 to 19, with all 19
no votes cast by Southern senators.
Every senator from outside the South, Republican
or Democrat, voted for the bill.
The House vote also divided sharply along
North-South lines.
Once the law was in place, southern states
challenged it in court, arguing it violated
the constitutional clause that gives states
the power to determine voter eligibility.
The Supreme Court rejected the challenge,
holding that another clause of the Constitution,
the 14th Amendment's equal protection clause,
took precedent.
The Voting Rights Act also temporarily banned
the use of literacy tests, which were later
banned completely by the Supreme Court.
Ratification of the 24th Amendment brought
the poll tax to an end.
Since passage of the Voting Rights Act in
1965, black voting has edged steadily upward
such that today the rate is not greatly different
from that of white voters.
Now if the politics of voting until the 1960s
were largely the politics of race, it has
since been a case of party politics as the
Republican and Democratic parties have jockeyed
for voting regulations that might help them
win elections.
A major target has been voter registration,
which is handled differently in the United
States than in Europe.
In European democracies, government assumes
responsibility for registering voters.
If a citizen moves to a new address, for example,
the postal service will notify election officials
to change the individual's registration.
The result is that over 90% of eligible European
voters are registered.
By comparison, only about 75% of vote-eligible
US citizens are registered.
The difference stems from the fact that registration
in the United States is the individual's responsibility.
Eligible citizens must personally take the
time to register.
Where government comes into this picture is
that it can make that process easier or harder.
If it lowers the barriers to registration,
you expand the electorate.
If it raises them, you shrink it.
So which political party do you think would
benefit from making registration easier?
The Democrats, the Republicans, both about
equally?
It's the Democrats.
Voting in the United States tilts heavily
toward those of higher income.
As you can see from this chart, the voting
rate among those in the top fifth of income
is far higher than those in the bottom fifth.
Income correlates with party preference.
Upper income voters tend to cast their votes
for Republican candidates, while those at
the bottom of the income ladder tend to vote
Democratic as a result of the party's leadership
and policies that benefit those of lower income
such as welfare services and the minimum wage.
The arithmetic of voting has not been lost
on the parties.
The Democratic Party has pressed hard to make
voter registration easier.
Its most notable success was the 1993 Motor
Voter Act.
The Act requires states to offer voter registrations
when they apply for a driver's license or
public assistance.
The Motor Voter bill first passed Congress
in 1991 when a Republican, George HW Bush,
was in the White House.
He vetoed it.
The Democratic-controlled Congress passed
it again in 1993.
This time a fellow Democrat, Bill Clinton,
was in office, and he signed the bill into
law.
In the Senate, only three Republicans backed
the bill, while all 59 Democrats did so.
Voting in the House also divided sharply along
party lines, with Republicans overwhelmingly
opposed and Democrats overwhelmingly in favor.
Studies of the Motor Voter Act indicate it
accounts for about 1/3 of new registrants.
To the surprise of both parties, however,
the number of new Democratic registrants resulting
from the law has only slightly outpaced the
number of new Republican registrants.
Now the Republican Party has worked the other
side of the fence, seeking to hold down voter
registration.
The centerpiece of this effort in recent years
has been voter ID laws.
In strictest form, an applicant must have
a government-issued photo ID such as a driver's
license or passport in order to register.
In other states with voter ID laws, other
forms of identification are acceptable as
long as they suggest the applicant is a citizen.
Now the express purpose of these laws is to
prevent voter fraud, to keep people who are
noncitizens from voting.
The real intent is different.
They are designed to make it difficult for
those without a formal ID to register.
About 10% of vote-eligible citizens do not
have a government-issued identification card.
And they are disproportionately young, poor,
and minorities.
All of these groups tend to vote Democratic.
The first voter ID laws were enacted by the
Republican-controlled legislatures of Georgia
and Indiana.
Of the roughly 30 states that have followed
their example, all but one, Rhode Island,
had a Republican-controlled legislature.
In a 6 to 3 ruling in 2008, the Supreme Court
upheld Indiana's law.
All six judges in the majority were Republican
appointees.
And though they acknowledged Indiana's law
had a partisan purpose, they said other purposes,
including the public's faith in the integrity
of the ballot, justified the ID law.
The Court said that the law "should not be
disregarded simply because partisan interests
may have provided one motivation for the votes
of individual legislators."
Research indicates that voter fraud is extremely
rare.
It appears that almost no one is willing to
risk being arrested and fined for illegal
voting.
Sometimes it's even tough to get legal voters
to show up at the polls.
On the other hand, research also indicates
that the suppressive effect of voter ID laws
is smaller than many opponents of the laws
have claimed.
It's still early in the history of these laws,
so their true impact is unlikely to be known
for some time.
Moreover, new legal challenges to voter ID
laws are currently working their way through
the courts, which could mean that the Supreme
Court might at some point take a second look
at the issue.
Finally, let's briefly examine partisan gerrymandering,
a tactic used by both parties.
After the population census every 10th year,
House seats are reapportioned to states on
the basis of their populations.
The more populous the state, the more House
seats it gets.
California, for example, has 53 House seats
while South Dakota has only one.
Under the Constitution, state legislatures
have the authority to set the boundaries of
House districts.
The majority party in these legislatures typically
divides up the state in a way that will help
its party's candidates, a process called gerrymandering.
The safe way to do this is to pack targeted
districts with enough of the party's voters
to assure victory in the election.
The other party is also likely to receive
safe seats.
This happens because if some districts are
stacked to the top with the opposing party's
votes, there will be fewer such voters in
other districts.
More than 85% of House seats today are uncompetitive,
virtually certain to be won by the candidate
of the stronger party.
There are several reasons for this, including
the fact that some states are so heavily Democratic
or Republican that it's hard to design competitive
districts.
But gerrymandering is among the reasons that
many House races are effectively decided before
a single vote is cast.
Now gerrymandering worked to Democrats' advantage
until the early 1990s, at which time an increasing
number of state legislatures came under Republican
control.
Republican legislatures did such a precise
job of gerrymandering after the 2010 census
that in the 2012 election, they won a comfortable
majority of House seats, even though Republican
candidates received fewer votes nationally
than did their Democratic opponents.
As gerrymandering has become ever more precise
as a result of computers, it has increasingly
come under legal challenges.
In 2004, the Supreme Court ruled on a case
centering on the redistricting plan enacted
by Pennsylvania's Republican governor and
legislature.
The suit alleged that the plan violated the
principle of one person, one vote and also
violated the Constitution's equal protection
clause.
The Republican-dominated Court ruled against
the challenge in a 5 to 4 vote, concluding
that the judiciary is not equipped to draw
district lines.
Any such attempt, said the Court's majority,
would require judges to make arbitrary decisions
about district boundaries.
Nevertheless, Justice Anthony Kennedy, who
voted with the majority, wrote that he would
not foreclose the possibility of judicial
intervention in the future, saying that a
truly outrageous districting plan, one that
carved a state into a set of bizarre-shaped
districts, could trigger action by the Court.
Now a few states, Iowa, California, and Montana
among them, have recently decided to place
redistricting in the hands of a nonpartisan
commission.
It's unlikely that a great many states will
follow their example, given the fact that
most state legislatures have signaled their
intent to retain control of redistricting.
Nevertheless, the Supreme Court in 2015 gave
voters in states that allow ballot initiatives
a remedy if they choose to exercise it.
The case centered on a redistricting commission
that Arizona's voters had created through
a ballot initiative.
The Arizona legislature brought suit, claiming
it alone had the constitutional authority
to determine the boundaries of the state's
House districts.
The Supreme Court ruled against the state
legislature and in favor of the state's voters.
It said that Arizona's voters had been acting
in a legislative capacity when they created
the redistricting commission.
OK, let's wrap up what we've covered in this
session.
We focused on representative government as
provided by the Constitution.
It was noted that the voters originally had
a say only in the election of House members,
a reflection of the framers' determination
to prevent a passionate majority from taking
control and running roughshod over the minority.
With time, due in part to the Jacksonian and
Progressive movements, popular voting came
to include Senate and presidential elections.
The adoption of primary elections and American
invention also served to shift power to the
voters.
Today, Americans vote more often for more
offices than voters elsewhere.
On the other hand, the public's influence
is diminished by partisan gerrymandering and
by the efforts of officials to manipulate
the size of the electorate through control
of the voter registration process.
Although these recent efforts pale alongside
those used in the past to keep black Americans
from voting, they are a source of court challenges
and intense partisan debate.
In other words, representative government
in America is still a work in progress.